a
[Música]
no dejar a nadie atrás con esta idea la
onu conmemora este año el día
internacional de los pueblos indígenas
el organismo alertó sobre una lentitud
de la vacunación a comunidades étnicas
de las amazonas en la triple frontera
entre colombia perú brasil por su parte
la directora de la organización
panamericana de la salud pidió que se
les dé prioridad en la vacunación contra
el hobbit 19 según el organismo regional
600 17.000 personas pertenecientes a
pueblos originarios en las américas se
han estado contagiadas con el virus y
casi 15.000 han muerto en colombia según
datos del instituto nacional de salud
más de 67 mil indígenas se han
contagiado en 1950 han fallecido estas
cifras indican que el porcentaje de
muertes en comunidades indígenas es del
2.9 por ciento superior al 2.5 por
ciento del registro nacional en el norte
y occidente del país las autoridades han
informado que algunas comunidades están
reacias a la vacunación porque
consideran que sus remedios ancestrales
son más efectivos que los fármacos
[Música]
a fundación en brasil los indígenas han
sido declarados grupo prioritario hasta
la fecha el 77% de los indígenas que
viven en aldeas han recibido las dos
dosis estamos hablando de unas 315 mil
personas y el 83 por ciento recibieron
una dosis sin embargo un estudio muestra
que la distribución de los inmunizantes
es desigual en las aldeas en las
comunidades donde hay más presencia de
iglesias evangélicas baja el nivel de
vacunación y aumenta la propagación de
efectivos por ejemplo que la vacuna
implantaría un chip en el cuerpo de los
indígenas algo que no es verdad además
recientemente hubo un escándalo
relacionado con las vacunas en las
tierras yanomami en el estado de roraima
en la frontera con venezuela se ha
descubierto que el menos 106 dosis de
vacunas destinada a los indígenas
habrían sido vendidas a mineros a cambio
de oro por parte de funcionarios del
ministerio de sanidad
[Música]
existen desafíos específicos para la
vacunación de muchos miembros de
comunidades indígenas en argentina
especialmente cuando viven en zonas
alejadas y cuando no hablan español una
estrategia implementada en el país ha
sido que los encargados de la vacunación
sean miembros de las comunidades habla
en su idioma o que sean acompañados por
un intérprete también se difundió
información en las lenguas que hablan
las comunidades como el guaraní o el
quechua de todos modos los pueblos
indígenas en toda américa latina también
en argentina suelen tener mayores
dificultades a la hora de enfrentar
necesidades de salud incluida la
pandemia de kobe 19 esto es consecuencia
de múltiples factores que van desde la
discriminación hasta las carencias
económicas de hecho ya en 2020 se
presenta un informe que daba cuenta de
que para ese entonces la pandemia había
agravado seriamente todos los aspectos
de la vida de los pueblos originarios de
argentina a los que pertenecen según el
dato más reciente del censo de 2010
cerca de un millón de personas
[Música]